bah je pense que oui oui oui il faut
encore expliqué il faut que les parents
soient impliqués il faut que les
enseignants et les parents ensemble
apprennent aux enfants comment faire
mais on ne peut pas laisser un boeing
747 par jour mourir ici en france et
continuer de faire comme si de rien
n'était et qui avait pas d'effort à
faire au niveau de chacun et ça c'est
pas possible
donc je pense que oui j'ai pas d'enfants
mais je pense que oui si j'ai la vie des
enfants
j'aurais expliquer mes enfants de porter
des masques chirurgicaux parce qu'ils
sont plus efficaces que les autres
masques fait maison
bon les masques chirurgicaux on les
reconnaît tout de suite mais pour les
masquer en tissu ça va être difficile
cela revient à demander aux instits de
faire un peu la police je pas sûr qu'il
soit très d'accord on va peut-être
bientôt avoir une grève non gens pour
qu'ils sont trop jeunes ils en
deviennent jours et nous avons bien
s'amuser te détendre à l'école il peut
pas voir la f1 peut pas ils vont pas
pouvoir respirer comme il faut je trouve
vraiment là c'est un peu trop alors ce
qu'on en pense que ce que je vois c'est
que c'est très bien parce que
effectivement il ya des masques qui
mascardi artisanaux qui sont un peu
moins efficace que les autres et dans le
contexte actuel il faut se protéger au
maximum
donc c'est bien que
même les enfants à l'école mais tu fais
les éviter du coup mortel des masques
chirurgicaux deux catégories une
alliance pour notre film était déjà des
masques chirurgicaux jetables pour
enfants donc ça changera pas grand chose
en fait honnêtement je pense que ça sera
pas du tout contrôler dans le sens où
ils ont chaque école a peut-être 200 300
enfants ils vont pas s'amuser le matin
je pense à vérifier c'est impossible
de toute façon ils poseront pas le temps
autrement on a créé un embouteillage
entre eux pour à l'entrée comme à la
sortie et ça sera contre productif au
contraire au droit
un regroupement de personnes et c'est
précisément ce qu'on veut éviter ben
pour l'instant là mon fils de 8 ans et
déjà avec un masque tout là toute la
journée donc ça va pas changer
énormément de choses pour lui mais je
pense que c'est important s'ils veulent
se protéger nous protéger aussi pour
l'instant je pense que c'est un gros
problème pour les directeurs et
directrices de crime r pour l'instant ce
qu'ils ont déjà beaucoup de travail à ce
niveau là mais j'imagine que c'est les
maîtres eux mêmes je pense pas qu'il y
aura de contrôle autres mais pour
l'instant on n'a pas eu d'informations
donc je sais pas voilà on a assez des
basques en tissu parce que c'était plus
écolo plus agréable pour les enfants et
voilà bon maintenant on apprend cette
nouvelle mesure et ben on va s'adapter
comme comme depuis quelques mois on a
déjà reçu des directives par l'école
donc les parents savent très bien ce
qu'il faut faire
et j'imagine que
chaque citoyen va être responsable de ce
qu'il va faire c'est une mesure de plus
c'est une mesure de plus pour pour
lutter contre la propagation des
variants apparemment c'est ce qui s'est
dit qu'on voulait éliminer les masque en
tissu parce qu'ils n'étaient pas assez
filtrant pour les les variants pour le
moment ça s'applique aux enfants mais
j'ai peur que ça redevienne facultative
à récompenser obligé d être aussi dans
peu de temps c'est une mesure qui de ce
que j'en ai entendu c'est que les
directeurs d'école sont sont pas très
d'accord pour faire la police est pour
beaucoup pour contrôler justement
l'application de la mesure
après je sais pas vraiment dans les
faits comment ça va s'appliquer je pense
que c'est la responsabilité des ide en
va de la responsabilité des parents
d'élèves
[Musique]